we are here with will bull hearts a so I
love your new setup dude why don't you
pull this down so I could see your face
bro okay
well like so you know what a thing it's
been a while since I've been here I know
but look at how I'm doing the mic it's
not permitted here
yeah alright well yeah well I know a
thing or two about chin yes help gonna
freak me out no this is good not good no
I just
it's weird cuz you got this here so you
and Brendan or I know bro Beecher and
then your guest is like yes well all the
time not if you keep the mic like yes if
you keep them I've seen it so I'm like
why is it this VM it if you could bring
the mic down like the other person who's
like interviewing you
yeah I get affiliate I get it a little
crab brother so where are the bodies
no you're just talking to the mic please
okay all right I want you to move it man
okay
man geez hey how are you this way
there you go so you want me like this I
just want you to sit against the thing
and be comfortable that's way better
okay all right is that Alright hey
credit no see it's now it's on here can
you hear mud you're the only guess just
had a problem with this you fart fart
new human scum miss the part of the kid
I would like to say this on wax here on
on the fighter in the kit when I get
messages from people that say hey bring
back that podcast and do this or do more
that I really appreciate that stuff and
I and I know that there has but there
are people that have listened to the
whole you know Tim and a podcast Canon
yeah and there's and there's talk about
reviving I've heard online this is
exactly online online people say that
this talk of that video more that we
there's no rumor there's people saying
that would be fun if you did that yeah
that's a route there's rumor yeah okay
call it rumor call it whatever you going
to happen anything can [ __ ] have it
you can have I could get up and plant my
left foot in on the bridge of your nose
and not hang into that oh and not that
ugly a stupid [ __ ] medieval
grandfather clock that you have for some
reason oh why do you have that you don't
come into my studio and start
threatening physical stuff because I'll
tell you something right now yeah Bob
right now yeah right now right okay you
come at me yeah yeah yeah what's gonna
happen I don't know what's gonna happen
but I do know one thing for sure right
you know for sure that I'm gonna I'm
gonna fall asleep on that mm-hmm that's
very disrespectful wait look at this if
you do you know what that is
what that's me in deep REM sleep
dreaming of you trying to come out not
dreaming of a you wait hold on this is
what I look like
hold on when I'm asleep and I'm dreams I
see out here I'm gonna show it to you
again
ready this is how I've severe sleep
apnea already
then this is me not breathing for a
minute and a half and then here's the
part where I dream of you ready and then
it goes getting purple no oxygen
definitely having a stroke watch the
world record for Will Sasso two minutes
18 seconds no oxygen and then more
dreaming you get the picture
oh my god so how am I going about what
would happen if I came at you I don't
know what would happen will I but if you
come at me and I know one thing 100% for
sure
right you'll [ __ ] your pain no you'll
[ __ ] your pillow no I want you insulting
son of a [ __ ]
if you come at me Wow piece you up I
mean that PC up is that something Brian
oh ok ok ok give me up yeah finish I
mean you give me a mish meat now my I
don't know I'll meet you halfway
yeah I'll meet you halfway yeah so
that's all I can guarantee that I'll
meet you halfway
Brian we cool cuz the ground is coming
at you quit right now the grounds coming
at you Craig right and you might want
them you might want to pull your pull my
what you shoot right your shirt right
pull my pull the rounds coming at you
quick
yeah it's coming at me quick so your mom
at this point right now yeah yeah at
this point right now yeah yeah yes I'm
I'm loose right feel good right so a
little hot yeah right yeah not some
caffeine gone ok right you're a little
excited and I'm feeling strong yeah
quick yeah right yeah so you might want
them on one or what grounds coming at ya
I wanna tell me getting me halfway
are you sure I'm not pulling those shoes
and I'm not pulling I'm you know um mr.
Crowley and it's fine it's coming yeah
yeah yeah it's coming real quick you
know I you know what you're drooling now
you [ __ ] drool your shirt yeah
because I'm cuz I'm foaming at the
[ __ ] mouth no cuz you're a beheading
cow your [ __ ] hand drooling with the
cud and its own tint mill huh you were
trying to suck your own teats and got
beheaded I don't wish you any ill
physically okay so that's why we can't
ever fought all right yep cuz those eyes
cuz you hide them toward a wall no you
know what you know what we have total
war you'd you you might want to yeah
well I I put on you into an evil beast
from him from an M night Shyamalan huh I
twist your head completely around
separate all your joints so that your
arms and legs at the knees go backwards
and you'd be like crawling up like on a
wall or someone somehow can or until
like that's what I'm gonna do like I'm
gonna feel light in MAGIX a so and I'm
gonna turn you into a horror movie
villain well until I counter I would
start with an eyelift okay and then
there's a problem area right around the
jowls there well and then I would I
would pin those ears back a bit what and
then I would definitely Botox the [ __ ]
out of that River like crease yeah I
wanna kill you a little bit of a nose
job yeah and a little nip tuck I've
never taken a punch to the face and yet
yes boxers nose yeah I'd replace your
lips completely [ __ ] yeah I'd put the
dollars in yeah and let's go ahead and
bring that hairline down and even it out
did and then you know looks and I'd fill
out this part here
look I don't know all the dry working
late yeah now now are you morphing into
a bloodhound I'm not happy with all
belong my face has become I'll be honest
and I understand now do you own a
bloodhound no because they say start to
turn into your dogs or to look like your
dog well you look like a damn good blood
handsome Corgi and a shepherd my face is
becoming very pointy I'm full of points
I won't call that plenty your face I'm
not mad at it though your face grows
like a root vegetable no no it's got
lines and it takes its own it just sort
of follows the soil no I feel it goes
character to my face it's a
distinguished face more like character I
love funds
I love puns I love doing comedy on your
podcast and sharing some puns
alright we should all be grateful and
thankful to be in this bizarre bizarre
Earling tempest nothingness did I ever
tell you because you yeah are a grown
man yeah lovely just a beautiful life
really you have a beautiful wife and
family yeah a beautiful home yeah
wonderful people who I want to enjoy
what you do like like here at the
fighter and the kid home and so many
things that you're doing like like not
just the Goldbergs
but now school's out or they call
schools in the old old fat schools
schools old don't it's no smoking in the
boys room what is it's called school
cool I just say right old school school
school school ii schooled school days so
school time and your do you be a day
anyway so and you got stuff like that
and you dropped out of high school and
never went to call my kid back drop
graduate from college that's a vicious
rumor so what were you saying before uh
all right well yeah guys oh yeah alright
just a couple of two gays there we go
it's a big bear in his little twink
there we go boys yeah yeah oh wow Will's
shorts just yelled fun Oh for the
listeners the wheel and grind they're
fighting I'm fighting Bryan's hit him
really hard really hard and then we'll
just lift him there and he's oh he just
spiked them down and Brian hit his heel
oh no I'll make out with him oh yeah out
block thanks sir
[Music]
and if somebody if any of you guys are
listening and know stuff about that semi
stuff on that I want to read about it
hold on a second station you sounded you
know I'm not gonna say you're not an
intelligent guy I know you're very
well-read but you sound like a stupid
idiot just then Wow you finished this
whole thing with your opinion you worded
it perfectly adding was fine and I was
like you know what then you go by the
way anyone lose to hazard stuff send it
that's not what I meant
I just meant there it would mean pills
and I like we are in the a and our own
some listeners who hate you for the most
part but you were filler right now
that's not that send me some good stuff
to read and it opens my eyes and I just
be a great dude who actually is very
very keen on making the world a better
place with all his money that's good
yeah so why I'm like [ __ ] you and all
you do is take oxygen you know I don't
yeah you do
no I don't you think oxygen you
shouldn't be here we're just I don't say
in America because I'm an American
citizen I mean as well as a Canadian
citizen first of all you're a foreigner
but second oh no I'm not I mean is I can
go why shouldn't be on the plan
oh I mean you should be but as I can go
all the way from the North Pole to down
to McAllen Texas
- you wouldn't survive one because I'm a
citizen of North America except for
Mexico
not really what do you mean Yanis is mmm
citizen my mmm oh yeah
an American citizen and I'm a Canadian
citizen I can't believe gonna go
wherever I want I'm the South Roman boom
boom in Mexico eatin Manny Pacquiao
unfished oculi watch the pacaya fight
alright keep going
I work with Kohlberg yes my brother yeah
you know do you know him have you worked
with him I know I have I mean I've met
him a couple but I said who's very nice
cuz I got no [ __ ] okay well you know
what what a weird thing to say out of
nowhere it kind of tells me who cares
yeah oh that's a big and muscular no
that's a dumb question no wrestling
family get a lift
he's got a who's your favorite
restaurant overall gives a [ __ ] this
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]